How do we compute such statistical correlations?
The Pearson correlation coefficient is
perhaps the best known indicator of correlation,
but this is suitable only for linear dependents.
That is if you have 2 ranges of values.
What we want instead is a correlation
between 2 binary values.
On 1 side we have the outcome of the run,
either fail or pass.
And then for each line we know that it's either covered or uncovered.
And we want to come up with a correlation
between coverage on one side,
and outcome of the run on the other side.
So the Pearson correlation coefficient is not appropriate for this.
But there is another measure for such correlation,
and it was also invented by Pearson.
It's called the Phi coefficient.
The Phi coefficient starts with a table.
In this table you count how frequently
a line was covered in failing runs
as well as in passing runs.
And of course you also count how frequently
it was not covered in failing runs
as well as in passing runs.
These 4 values take the names N11, N10, N01, and N00, respectively.
Where the first digit stands for covered versus uncovered,
and the second digit stands for fail versus pass.
You also compute sums over all rows
as well as sums over all columns
as well as the total sum of events.
This then is the Phi coefficient.
It consists of multiplying the values in the first diagonal
and subtracting the product of the second diagonal.
This is then normalized according to the
square root of the sums of the columns and rows.
The Phi coefficient is high if 1 diagonal has a high value
and the other diagonal has a low value.
If it is this diagonal, which has a high value that's down here,
then it becomes positive.
If it's this diagonal, which has a higher value,
then it becomes negative.
So the higher the value in 1 diagonal
and the lower the value in the other diagonal,
the stronger the correlation.
Our plan now is we compute the Phi correlation for each line,
and then we rank the lines from high correlation to low correlation.
And we start, of course, with the strongest correlation.
Let me illustrate how the Phi coefficient
is computed on a simple example.
Let's assume that we have a line in our program and a number of runs.
In the first run, line 10 is executed, and the run fails.
So what we enter in the table for this line is that
we now have seen 1 instance where it covered and failed.
Next thing that happens with this line is that it's
not covered and the run passes.
So we add a 1 in this part of the table.
Next thing we see, it's covered and it fails.
So the value on that table becomes 2.
And then again, we see uncovered and it passes.
So now we have seen 2 instances
of the line being uncovered and passing.
Let's assume these are just the 4 runs that we observe.
Then we have seen no instance of the line being covered and passing
and no instance of the line being uncovered and failing.
Let's quickly sum up the remaining rows and columns.
We have seen 2 instances where the line was covered
and 2 where it was uncovered.
We have seen 2 instances where it failed
and 2 instances where it passed.
The total number of events is 4.